royal politique toujours avec une
question qui revient au coeur du débat
celle de la police de proximité
souhaitée par ségolène royal dans son
pacte présidentiel
oublié par le ministre de l'intérieur
nicolas sarkozy la voilà à nouveau
relancé par le candidat ump à l'élection
présidentielle le point avec loïc de la
mornais et bruno girodon en ce jour de
février 2003 nicolas sarkozy nouveau
ministre de l'intérieur inflige une
leçon au chef de la police toulousaine
arrière de la police l'investigation
l'interpellation la lutte contre la
délinquance ont réalisé un match de
rugby pour les jeunes du quartier c'est
bien c'est pas la mission première de le
plus depuis la police de proximité
initiée par la gauche en 1998 a disparu
et le commissaire toulousain a été nommé
président de la fédération sportive de
la police
pourtant aujourd'hui la police de
proximité revient dans le débat
mieux tous les candidats semblent
d'accord c'est juste une question de
vocabulaire
le candidat de l'ump toujours ministre
de l'intérieur vient de former un comité
d'experts sur la police de quartier
manière de jouer sur les mots san fermin
de revenir en arrière
il reste encore discret sur ce
revirement sur la police de quartier
pourquoi
et plupart des polices de proximité
ségolène royal elle n'a jamais changé
d'avis dans son pacte présidentiel elle
reprend le concept d'une police de
proximité chère à la gauche
même si elle appelle également police de
quartier
aujourd'hui le démantèlement de ce
service public de proximité a créé des
zones de non-droit et moi je crois
beaucoup à la police de quartier si
c'est dans mon projet présidentiel
police de quartier parce que c'est une
police qui est au plus près des
habitants qui est donc respectée par les
habitants et réciproquement
françois bayrou innove dans le
vocabulaire parlant d'une police
fidélisée
on a besoin d'une police d'une police
certains disent de proximité nous nous
disons à l'invitation de jean christophe
lagarde une police fidélisée une police
qui soit capable d'interpeller les
gamins en les appelant par leur nom
quant au front national il évoque une
réorganisation administrative et parle
de commissariats de quartier
nous nous voulons remettre de l'ordre
dans ces quartiers-là notamment par le
retour des commissariats dans les
quartiers des plus difficile puisqu'on a
enlevé les commissariats de ces
quartiers là ils formaient des policiers
au centre de la cité quelle qu'elle soit
il n'y a pas de territoire de république
interdit le retour d'une police proche
des quartiers était souhaité par une
majorité de syndicats
rapprocher la police de la population
n'a jamais fait une balle à personne au
contraire à chaque fois pour la cruelle
et faisait défaut séance et ce qui s'est
passé al'inverse de 2002 la police de
proximité vient de faire rentrer le
thème de la sécurité par la petite porte
d'une campagne qui jusqu'ici a
pudiquement éludé la question